I will describe ninth to as a mad house
but a controlled mad
house there are a couple of scenes of
Night 2 that I love there's such a a
depth of characters and so many
interesting characters and I think the
action design just pushes it to the next
level it's great to direct action that
good action also has good
drama
action needs to be set up
emotionally in episode two Winston is
grieving and he's incredibly sad but at
the end of the day he's still Winston
the conman businessman I think what's
important for Winston as a character is
to make him vulnerable and likable and
also get a sense of that toughness and
that hardness that we see in Winston in
the movies and because he wants to kill
Cormac
he needs a team if I had to describe
night two in one word team building
they're criminals but they're not
criminals without some code the world of
the Continental you're just a killer or
you're going to be killed everyone's
looking for a way to readjust to what
the death can bring to a family and the
extent of how far that Ripple
appears it's probably our most serious
episode because we're dealing with the
grief and the loss of a brother and the
repercussions of
that Frankie to Ian is like the light at
the end of the tunnel so she tried to
take
[Music]
revenge you had no
right I know I'm sorry Winston States
I'm going to kill Cormac but he also
lays out for them we're all in this now
they're going to come for us we're going
to die anyways ultimately you have no
choice if we kill
Cormac we're not only taking his life we
are taking his goddamn house and
everything that comes with it no longer
will you be a middleman living outside
the system you will be the system that's
what's cool about Winston is he's he's
just clever he's smart he that's that's
his power it's not kicking someone's ass
it's outsmarting them we don't serve
your kind here that's good because I
don't eat my
kind
you do meet the bower Queen in episode 2
who is the predecessor of Lawrence
fishburns bowy King and John Wick you
must be the son of a everyone's
looking for there's this character from
real life named Maisy who was the queen
of the bowy from a historical point of
view that was something that we went oh
let's pull into that she can't be paid
bought off Winston has to work hard hard
to get her trust because he needs an
army to take down
[Music]
Cormac Winston is not sure at all that
he got her on his side and he knows
after seeing the tunnels how powerful
her organization is I'm very resourceful
tell me what you need
no it's too
easy Ah
that's
the fans recognize things that are
coming from the John Wick
[Music]
movies in the movie franchise you see
these gold
coins what value do these coins have you
can buy a drink with one you can hire
someone to kill can get a hotel room
with someone if you have this coin you
are part of this under
Underworld the cinematography is
absolutely amazing it's beautiful I have
to say wow the series is a really fun
place to explore a lot and answer a lot
of questions that we aren't able to in
the movies we're showing a connected
tissue between the generation before and
then what the generation now will bring
forward to when John Wick
appears the trainers we have are the
best in the world
and and they've also worked on the
movies I'm actually learning how to do K
know and we're making contact it has
been
intense when Winston approaches Chiron
there's definitely a lot of anger
because Chiron represents the evil the
Cormac side of things and I think that
is really where the confidence stems
from lovely to see you again Chiron he
comes from a rich Nigerian culture based
on respect and loyalty Winston
encourages Chiron to think about people
he's allowing to influence
[Music]
him what I'm asking you to do is not
easy it may go against everything you
stand for your loyalty and your honesty
and it will mean keeping
secrets I'm offering you a chance to
decide who you want to be before it's
too
[Music]
late
loyalty there's a fight to be at the top
of the food
chain I'm looking forward to night three
it's going to be
fun